let's say someone has got a full-time
job and they love the idea of I want to
make a living doing what I love how
would we break that down so if you're an
employee when you make the switch you're
still an employee you're just employee
of a different business that you happen
to own and you are basically 100 of the
expenses and so the business itself
actually makes no money the thing that
most people have to do is they have to
go get money and the way you do that is
you sell stuff which means you have to
make your products known and we do that
through advertising start doing it on a
consistent basis bring people in what do
you sell them that's what 100 million
offers this book is for us and then you
sell them the thing and then after that
you'll have some delivery usually if you
have a consistent method of advertising
and selling then you can start getting
people to help you and then you can
increase your advertising sales is a
very high leverage thing in the
beginning if you spend all day selling
just you you would have enough for five
people to do work right and so then you
would have a business